do you think in your lifetime we will
build an agi system
that
would
undeniably be a thing that achieves
human level intelligence and goes far
beyond
i definitely think it's possible
um
that it will go far beyond but i'm
definitely convinced that it will be
human level intelligence
um and i'm i'm hypothesizing about the
beyond because
the beyond beat
is a bit tricky to define
especially when we look at the current
formula of
starting from this imitation learning
standpoint right so we can certainly
imitate
humans
um at language and beyond
so
getting at human level through imitation
feels very possible going beyond
will require
reinforcement learning and other things
and i think in some areas
that certainly already has paid out i
mean go being an example that's my
favorite so far in terms of going beyond
human capabilities but in general
i'm not sure we can define reward
functions
that from a seat of imitating human
level intelligence that is general and
then going beyond
that that bit is not so clear in my
lifetime but certainly um human level
yes and i mean that in itself is already
quite powerful i think so um going
beyond i think it's obviously not we're
not gonna not try that if if if then we
get to superhuman scientists and
discovery and advancing the world but
but at least human level is also in
general is also very very powerful
well especially if human level
or slightly beyond is integrated deeply
with human society and there's billions
of agents like that
do you think there's a singularity
moment beyond which
our world will be just
very deeply transformed by these kinds
of systems because now you're talking
about intelligence systems that are just
i mean this is no longer just a
going from
horse and buggy to to the car
it feels like a very different kind of
shift
in what it means to be a living entity
on earth
are you afraid are you excited of this
world i'm i'm afraid if there's a lot
more um so i think maybe we'll need to
think about um if we truly get there
just
thinking of
limited resources like you know humanity
clearly hits some limits and then
there's some balance hopefully that
biologically um the planet is imposing
and we we should actually try to get
better at this as we know there's
there's quite a few
you know issues with having too many
people um coexisting in a resource
limited way so for digital entities it's
an interesting question i think such a
limit maybe should exist
but maybe it's going to be imposed by
energy
availability because this also consumes
energy in fact most systems are
more inefficient than we are in terms of
energy required
but definitely i think as a society
we'll need to
just work together to find
what would be reasonable in terms of
growth or how we coexist if that is um
to happen
i am very excited about
obviously the aspects of automation that
make people that obviously don't have
access to certain resources or knowledge
um
for them to have those that access i
think those are the applications in a
way that i'm most exciting to see
um and to personally work towards yeah
there's going to be significant
improvements in productivity and the
quality of life across the whole
population which is very interesting but
i'm looking even far beyond
us becoming a multi-planetary species
and uh just as a quick bet last question
do you think
as humans become multi-planetary species
go outside our solar system
all that kind of stuff do you think
there will be more humans or more robots
in that future world so will humans be
the quirky
uh intelligent being of the past or is
there something deeply fundamental to
human intelligence that's truly special
where we we will be part of those other
planets not just ai systems
i think we'll we're all excited to
build
agi to
empower
or make us more powerful as human
species not to say there might be some
hybridization i mean this is obviously
speculation but there are companies also
trying to
um the same way medicine is is making us
better maybe there are other other
things that are yet to happen on that
but
if the ratio is not at most one to one i
would not be happy so i would hope that
we are part of the equation
um but maybe
there's maybe a one-to-one ratio feels
like possible um constructive and so on
but it would not be good to have a
misbalance at least from my core beliefs
and
the why i'm doing what i'm doing when i
go to work and i research what i
research
well this is how i know you're human and
this is how you've passed the turing
test
and you are one of the special humans or
it's a huge honor that you would talk
with me and i hope we get the chance to
speak again maybe once before the
singularity once after and see how our
view of the world changes thank you
again for talking today thank you for
the amazing work you do you're a
shining example of a researcher and a
human being in this community thanks a
lot lex yeah looking forward to before
the singularity certainly
and maybe after yes definitely as well
you